Rihanna is with us in Arizona hi Briana
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show my baby
it's great to speak with you you too
what's up um so I started listening to
you background on September October time
and I've been on fire since um I'm
engaged and I'll be getting married in
about four months and thank you and I
had kind of a hard time you know getting
him on board for when we are married and
we should get the ball rolling he has a
lot more debt than I am and he's an
accountant
so I think that might be where my
challenge comes in I tried bringing you
up in October and it didn't go well he
mentioned he felt good I guess I was um
like an undermining his knowledge of
Finance in a sense and I kept he's 25
and then 26 yeah
and how much pre-marriage counseling did
you do none looking at the place you
need some you need to get in touch with
your church immediately or your friends
Church immediately and have someone
counsel you guys in pre-marriage
counseling this is not a financial issue
your husband-to-be does not respect your
opinion that's not good right
okay let me add to it okay the number
one cause of divorce in North America
today is money fights and money problems
you are going into your marriage
disagreeing about the area that causes
the most divorces Danger Danger Danger
does this mean put off the marriage no
but it does mean get this solved it is
vital that the two of you get on the
same page you know my my youngest child
is 28 and married
two years ago okay so if you were one of
them if either one of you or my child I
would be up in your grill not because
I'm Dave Ramsey but because this is such
a vital area of you having a high
quality relationship regardless of Dave
Ramsey or what you heard from me or him
not believing in me that's not the point
the point is he didn't he's unwilling to
listen to you and you're not in
agreement on debt and he's an accountant
who's deeply in debt that's weird
he's a mechanic whose car is broken what
that's weird
and so and he's insecure about it and
unwilling to talk to you about it and
you undermined his authority he's 25 he
doesn't have authority he has an
accounting degree so now that's a dad
talking did you hear me that's your old
Uncle Dave telling you the way life is
so it's not about it's not about whether
you follow my plan or not okay I really
want you guys to do the pre marriage
work that you need to do and get on the
same page on this money issue
because and it's just vital that you do
because you're going to struggle in your
relationship and you're going to
struggle in your finances unless you can
get on the same page and stay aligned
just I happen I'm sorry one more quick
question
so today he actually texted me which is
why I called about wanting to buy a
house next year which obviously we're
not ready for so that's why I called it
a Fiat it could be a good like segue
into getting on the same page and you
know finding all why but every time I
bring up a budget he kind of goes back
on like Oh budgets are unrealistic and
you know and he knows a lot because he
is nothing but debt exactly some say you
guys have got you you really have some
issues here that you're gonna have to
get solved I just see all kind
a danger and I don't want anything but
good things for you and for him but you
guys are already having major stress
points and arguments over the number one
cause of divorce that is a very big deal
and so you really really really need to
do the work to get that saw please
please do not marry this guy unless you
can get on the same page I think you can
do the work and get on the same page but
he's being an arrogant little twit right
now and he really is and you know he's
unwilling to listen to you he's got all
the answers and the problem is I know
this guy I used to be him and in life
won't knock him down until he quits
being that guy so that's yeah please
please please let's get past this and
the two of you sit down together and get
some pre marriage counseling and that's
you know please don't get married unless
you can get on the same page
you're gonna he's going to treat you
this way on other issues every time you
bring something up he rolls his eyes and
goes you're not smart that's what I'm
hearing and that's not gonna be okay
that's not gonna work catherine is gonna
be up after the break that this is the
Dave Ramsey show thank you for joining
us America if the number one cause of
divorce in America today were anything
you would make sure that item if you
filled in the blank on that and you were
engaged you would make sure that item or
handled the number one way you died is a
certain thing you would avoid that thing
right because you don't die this is not
I mean this is simple so you really do
have to look at this stuff and realize
that you're not the exception to this
all of us are not the exception to this
the borrower is slave to the lender
you're not the exception I'm not the
exception